في مدينه حارم بادلب اختفت البيوت لتحل
محلها خيام هنا وهناك لكن الفرق بين عدد
البيوت التي تحولت الى ركام والعدد القليل
من الخيام التي نصبت شاسع جدا هنا تولد
احساس لدى الناس ان العالم تركهم يواجهون
مصيرهم وحدهم بعد الزلزال
اول قافله ارسلتها الامم المتحده عبر معبر
باب الهوى للمتضررين شمال غربي سوريا دخلت
بعد سته ايام من الزلزال والثانيه دخلت
بعد اليوم السابع قافلتان في سبعه ايام
لمواجهه كارثه مدمره سوريون رسموا العلم
الاممي مقلوبا وكتبوا عليه الامم المتحده
خذلتنا تلخص الصوره الشعور العامه في شمال
غربي سوريا يدعمها كلام وكيل الامين
العامل للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
الذي قال ان المجتمع الدولي خذل من يعيشون
في شمال غرب سوريا وانهم محقون في شعورهم
بان المجتمع الدولي تخلى عنهم ودعا الى
معالجه ما وصفه بالفشل في اسرع وقت ممكن
اما المبعوث الاوروبي الى سوريا فقد دعا
دمشق الى عدم تاسيس ملف المساعدات
الانسانيه ورفضت اتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي
بالتقصير في تقديم ما يكفي من المساعدات
السوريين ماذا يقصد المبعوث الاوروبي
بتاسيس المساعدات هل هو اتهام مبطن للنظام
السوري بمنع وصول المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه رغم اعلانه السماح بذلك حتى الان
لم ترد اي معلومات تشير الى ان مساعدات
دوليه عبرت من مناطق نفوذ النظام الى
مناطق المعارضه
في دمشق تتحدث منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
انتظار موافقه من الطرف الاخر للعبور الى
مناطق شمال غربي سوريا لم يحصل السوريون
في هذه المناطق على المساعده لانقاذ من
يمكن انقاذهم في الايام التي ثلاث الزلزال
باعتراف الجميع الان المجتمع الدولي امام
اختبار اكبر فكارثه الزلزال تكشف عن وجوه
قبيحه عده تحتاج مساعدات على مدى شهور
وربما سنوات
كثيرون مثل محمد حاج حسين فقدوا بيوتهم
تقول الامم المتحده ان خمسه ملايين
وثلاثمائه الف سوري اصبحوا دون ماوى بسبب
الزلزال قضى في الزلزال من قضى وبقي عدد
مخيف من الجرحى والايتام والارامل
سيحتاجون مساعدات هائله بعيدا عن حسابات
السياسه